Hannover ist Tabellenführer, die nächsten Trainerwechsel sind vollzogen und die 2. Liga ist mal wieder in Kuschellaune. Wir blicken mit Kölnexperte Jan Lukas Elskamp und Michael Fischer vom Fürther Flachpass und den Nürnberger Nachrichten auf die Liga im Generellen und schauen uns genauer an, was bei Köln und Fürth los ist. Viel Spaß! Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk. Ja, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe der Ligatour zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle und freue mich wirklich sehr, dass ich wieder gemeinsam mit tollen Gästen auf diese Liga schauen darf nach elf gespielten Spielen. Zum einen darf ich da an meiner Seite begrüßen Jan Lukas Elskamp, um– ja, du sprichst hier heute mit uns über den mehr oder weniger glorreichen FC Köln. Schön, dass du dabei bist.
Ja, mir ist aufgefallen, ich glaube, so das Erste, was ja einfach rein, wenn man einfach draufguckt, auf die Ausstellung, er hat ja, glaube ich, auf Viererkette umgestellt. Also in der Zorniga war ja meistens eigentlich immer 3-H-5er-Kette oder beziehungsweise 3-H-5er-Kette. Und ich meine, klar, also wie du schon sagst, so eine verunsicherte Mannschaft, ich glaube nicht, dass man jetzt auf dieses System direkt sagen kann, okay, damit hat man jetzt aber irgendwie neugierige Gegentore kassiert in drei Spieltagen. Das funktioniert schon mal nicht. Sondern es ist ja, also wie du schon sagst, ja durchaus doppelt undankbar. Also sowohl ist es ja nicht sein Kader, der, der für den Kader verantwortlich ist, ist auch nicht mehr da. Also diese Mannschaft ist verunsichert und die Defensive, die kriegst du auch nicht mal eben zusammen. Und es ist ja glaube ich auch noch so, hattest du im Vorgespräch auch geschrieben, Fürth hätte sogar noch mehr Gegentore kassieren müssen. Deutlich mehr. Deutlich mehr. Also am deutlichsten mehr. Ich habe es auch nochmal rausgesucht, hätte Hannover kassieren müssen. Die müssten nämlich stand jetzt eigentlich fast acht Gegentore mehr haben. Das ist schon absurd, wenn wir eben über die Defensive gesprochen haben. Aber ich finde es halt so schwierig, weil da kommen so viele Dinge zusammen. Jetzt hat er sich, glaube ich, auch noch unbeliebt gemacht. So ein bisschen, weil er, glaube ich, sich etwas unglücklich auf der Pressekonferenz vor dem Darmstadt-Spiel geäußert hat, im Sinne von, ja, hier bitte nicht nur bei Siegen feiern und bei Niederlagen ausfeifen. Führte dann, glaube ich, auch zu einem Stimmungsbalkott auf jeden Fall irgendwann im Darmstadt-Spiel.
Also nicht wegen dieser PK, dieser Stimmungsbalkott natürlich, aber es kam jetzt nicht sonderlich gut an, weil jeder kennt ja Fürth und kennt die Fürther-Fanszene. Die ist nicht sonderlich groß und das sind aber halt über 1000 Menschen nach Schalke gefahren. Das waren über 3000 in Regensburg beim Pokalspiel und die haben da dauerhaft gesungen. Und dann wurde natürlich nach diesem Pokal aus, aufgrund der angestauten Boot, kann man ja auch verstehen, diese Derby-Niederlage war schon krass für Fürth. Also viele Menschen in meinem Alter oder jünger haben es eben nie erlebt, dass man ein Derby so hoch verloren hat. Und seit 1970, da waren einige Menschen nicht geboren, die im Stadion waren. Und da hat diese Abfolge der ganzen Dinge, dann Pokalspiele in Fürth sind eh schon heikel, weil man gefühlt jedes Jahr schallt in der ersten oder in der zweiten Runde. Man hat zuletzt 2018 ein Pokalheimspiel und das war, weil man Platz 15 war und dadurch in der ersten Runde ein Heimspiel hatte. Und dann ist man auch ausgeschieden gegen Borussia Dortmund. Ja, und das ist natürlich dann bitter. Und dann wurde in Regensburg gepfiffen, ja, auch so laut wie ich selten erlebt habe in Fürth. Und da merkt man dann die Unerfahrenheit eines Trainers in solchen Situationen, dann sagt man sowas halt einfach nicht. Also ein erfahrener Trainer hätte das nicht gesagt. Nicht pfeifen, weil es war für ihn einfach eindrücklich, weil bei seinem zweiten Spieler halt extrem laut gepfiffen wurde. Und er kann nichts dafür, für alles, was vorher war. Er kann nichts für den Pokal aus. Vor einem Jahr gegen vierteligsten FC Homburg, vor zwei Jahren gegen fünftelige Stuttgarter Kickers, da kann er nichts dafür. Aber die Menschen in Fürth sind halt einfach irgendwann auch genervt, dass sie hören, jedes Jahr man hat kein Geld und dann schenkt man jedes Jahr mindestens 800.000 Euro oder mehr her. Das würde ja kumuliert dann auch irgendwann mal zwei Millionen ergeben, bei denen man mal einen Spieler halten könnte, womöglich oder einen Spieler verpflichten könnte. Und muss ich mal sagen, wir müssen jetzt noch von der berühmten Reste Ramperspieler verpflichten, weil wir haben kein Geld. Da ist halt viel zusammengekommen. Und wie gesagt, das war undankbar. Und klar, dieses Spiel gegen Darmstadt, das war der absolut, das Witzige war, wir hatten eine Podcast-Folge, die hieß Tiefpunkt. Und dann haben wir den Tiefpunkt des Tiefpunkts gesucht. Und ich bin ein bisschen in Marianne-Graben bei der Recherche abgestiegen, um zu schauen, was der wirkliche Tiefpunkt der Welt ist. Der Tiefpunkt war auf jeden Fall dieses Spiel gegen Darmstadt. Deswegen wirkt die Mannschaft wirklich tot in diesem Spiel. Du hast vorhin gesagt, jetzt fünf Gegentore davor gegen Nürnberg, vier auf Schalke, drei gegen extrem verunsicherte Schalker. Man hätte 25 bis 27 Tore kassieren müssen, hat jetzt aber auch 22 kassiert. Es hat ein bisschen auch so drüber hinweg getäuscht unter der Saison, denn man hat schon die ganzen Saisonprobleme mit der Defensive. Am ersten Spieltag hatte Preußen Münster schon über drei Expected Goals entführt, aber dann war die individuelle Qualität nicht so hoch, dass die drei Tore gemacht haben. Deshalb hat man 3-1 gewonnen. Zwischenzeitlich hat man mal eine Differenz zwischen XG und den realen Toren von 10. Und da weiß ja jeder, der ein bisschen sich mit Statistik auskennt, dass es da die berühmte Regression zur Mitte gibt, die ja auch im Rasenfunk schon oft genannt wurde. Und ich habe diese Regression zur Mitte sogar im Podcast und glaube ich auch in der PK mal angesprochen. Und dann hieß es immer, wir hätten sie ja nicht kassiert, hat Alexander Zorniger gesagt. Das war seine Erklärung, man habe die Tore ja nicht kassiert. Ich habe dann mal gesagt, man wird sie aber irgendwann kassieren und ich will kein Klugscheißer sein, aber man kassiert sie halt jetzt regelmäßig. Man hat ja schon vor dem Derby immer drei Spiele lang immer zwei Tore kassiert und man weiß ja, in der 2. Liga steigt man oft halt einfach auch auf, wenn man wie an U-96 öfter mal 1-0 oder 2-1 gewinnt und nicht wenn man öfter mal 2-2 spielt oder halt 1-5 verliert. Insofern ist eine gute Defensive schon sehr wichtig und das Krasse ist ja auch, diese Mannschaft ist in der Defensive nicht komplett neu zusammengestellt. Und letztes Jahr hat Fürth mal fünf Spiele in Folge zu Null gespielt unter Zorniger, auch mal in der Hinrunde. Also es gab fünf, ich glaube vier Siege an Unentschieden oder fünf Siege. Zumindest gab es fünf Spiele zu Null. Also und davon sind noch viele da. Luca Eder ist noch da, Marco Maio ist da, Simon Astor, Gideon Jung. Also es sind ja alle Spiele, die letztes Jahr auch schon da waren. Auch da, wenn Michael Zorniger gar keine Rolle mehr gespielt hat, obwohl er mal zwischenzeitlich der beste 2. Liga-Verteidiger war. Ja, also die können es eigentlich, aber irgendwie wirkt alles seltsam gelähmt. Das war auch die Formulierung von Stefan Fürster nach dem Schalke-Spiel, nach dem Darmstadt-Spiel, dass alles seltsam gelähmt wirkt. Und natürlich ist es schwierig, als eine gelähmte Mannschaft, die jetzt auch schon diese ganzen, ja trotzdem einige Misserfolge der letzten Jahre erlebt hat, da waren viele in der Bundesliga auch dabei, die haben den Bundesliga-Abstieg mitgemacht. Die haben dieses krasse erste Jahr nach dem Bundesliga-Abstieg in der 2. Liga mitgemacht, letztes Jahr diese Achterbahnfahrt. Deswegen glaube ich auch, dass es für Fürth vor allem darum geht, diese Saison jetzt irgendwie zu retten. Man wird dann, glaube ich, nicht oben mitspielen, dafür ist die Kaderqualität auch nicht ausreichend. Man darf nicht absteigen, also weil das ist für Fürth tödlich, weil man halt sehr stark auf Fernsehgelder angewiesen ist, noch mehr als andere Vereine und dann ist viel schon mal die Formulierung, zwei Jahre in der 3. Liga hält man aus, mehr ist schwierig, weil halt der Verein einfach sonst keine großen Einnahmen hat und darum geht es. Und dann glaube ich, geht es einfach darum, auch dann das wirklich zu resetten, den Reset-Knopf, den berühmten Fußball zu drücken, weil es laufen die Verträge nahezu aller Spieler in der Defensive aus und das wäre ja ein Ansatzpunkt, da vielleicht nicht alle zu verlängern, sondern auch mal die berühmte Blutauffrischung. Vielleicht wollen wir mit diesen Fußball-Phrasen um mich und Schloss gehen, aber einfach da auch mal wieder dafür zu sorgen, dass da einfach andere Spielertypen auch sind, die nicht diese letzten drei Jahre miterlebt haben, sondern auch mal Spieler. Andere, Verteidigungsmonster, hat Alexander Zondelger, Marc Sack, die habe man nicht in Fürth. Vielleicht braucht man mal Verteidigungsmonster, wenn man halt nicht verteidigen kann.
Ja, ganz kurze Frage noch zum Abschluss. Ich weiß, das ist ein bisschen gemein. Aber wie geht es denn sonst für dich jetzt weiter? Also hat Leo Haas die nötige Lizenz, um da auch Chef-Trainer zu sein? Michi nickt für alle, die es nicht sehen können. Aber ist es, also du scheinst ja sonst, du hast eben schon gesagt, du findest ihn sonst einen sehr interessanten Trainer. Also wäre das für dich auch jemand, der schafft, diese Warnschaft aus dieser Verunsicherung wieder rauszukommen? Also man muss ja sagen, zum Glück ist ja fast auch wieder Länderspielpause. Ich glaube, da freut sich Führt tatsächlich sehr besonders drauf, weil man einfach vielleicht auch einfach mal Wochenende kopffrei kriegen kann, so blöd, wie das auch klingt. Aber ist ja jetzt schon übel gewesen mit der englischen Woche. Jetzt geht es gegen Köln, wir wissen es alle jetzt. Dann zu Hause gegen Karlsruhe und aus jetzt gegen Ulm. Das ist jetzt auch einfach nicht das einfachste Programm, was jetzt auf einen wartet.
Da kommen ja noch weitere Spieler gegen Hannover und den HSV zum Beispiel. Also es kommt in Fürth schon ab und zu jetzt mal die Formulierung auf. Also zumindest von der Fan-Seite. Es wäre gut, noch einmal zu gewinnen. Mindestens irgendwie noch unentschieden, dass man so 17 Punkte zu Winterpause hat. Also weil natürlich ja es schwer vorstellbar ist, wie diese Hannover 690 in dieser Form, wie Fürth da gewinnen soll. Also noch dazu, das haben wir jetzt gar nicht besprochen. Fürth war unter Zornäcker auch vor allem sehr heimstark. Man war letztes Jahr 8. in der Tabelle, war aber halt in der Heimtabelle Platz 3. Man hat fast immer zu Hause gewonnen. Mittlerweile ist man Platz 15 in der Heimtabelle und hat einmal gewonnen und nur 5 Punkte geholt zu Hause. Das ist im Abstiegskampf auch schwierig, wenn man selbst zu Hause nicht mehr gewinnt. Aber weil du gerade die Länderspielpause angesprochen hast, ich bin gespannt, ob Leo Haas die bekommt. Wenn man jetzt in Köln wieder so untergeht, dann kann es natürlich auch sein, dass man sagt, man nutzt diese Länderspielpause für einen weiteren Reset. Dann muss man es ja fast machen. Wenn man jetzt in Köln wieder fünf Torekassee, was ja passieren kann bei der offensiven Bucht des FC, was, wenn Tim Lemberle alles an der Chance macht, auch passieren kann. Ich würde es Leo Haas gönnen. Du hast vorhin gefragt, er hat die notwendige Lizenz, er hat die Pro-Lizenz, ist Fußballlehrer, hat er auch gemacht. Wie gesagt, ein Trainer, der auch mehr Fußball spielen will. Ich bin mit Alexander Zorniger manchmal auch aneinander geraten, weil er immer gesagt hat, ich soll aufhören, immer über diesen Viertelflachpass zu reden. Das ist alles lang her. Zorniger war nicht unbedingt derjenige, der im Training auch extrem viel Wert auf gutes Fußballspiel gelegt hat, sondern das war halt immer in irgendeiner Form eine Simulation des Pressings und Gegenpressings. Und Leo Haas hat schon von Anfang an gesagt, er war früher Zehner, also der will Fußball spielen, hat Marz auf Schalke ja auch gesehen. Sie haben mehr Fußball gespielt. Da gab es eine eindrückliche Szene, dass Maxi Dietz, der Verteidiger, beim Abschluss weggelaufen ist von Nahuel Noll. Und dann wurde er zusammengeschissen vom Trainer, dass er gefälligst nach hinten laufen und den Pass fordern soll. Und dann haben sie flach aufgebaut von hinten. Und das als bekennender Freund des schönen Fußballspiels. Gefällt mir das natürlich, wenn ein Trainer mehr Fußball spielen will. Insofern finde ich es halt bitter, dass es gerade so blöd läuft. Man hat aber schon dieses Bemühen, mehr Fußball zu spielen gesehen. Gegen Schalke war das sehr erfolgreich. Klar, das lag auch um FC Schalke, der einfach gar nicht verteidigt hat in dem Spiel. Das ist auch krass. Wenn du gegen Fürth so aussiehst, in dieser Form, ist es schon besorgniserregend. Klar, wenn du als Fürth so aussiehst wie gegen Darmstadt, ist es auch besorgniserregend. Es hängt vieles von dem Spiel am Wochenende ab. Es wurde auch schon von Holger Schwiewackner gesagt, natürlich sondieren wir den Markt. Das heißt, das spricht für mich dafür, dass Leo Haas dieses Spiel bekommt. Es spricht keiner von Ultimatum. Wenn man jetzt 1 zu 2 knapp verliert und eine gute Leistung zeigt, dann kann es sein, dass er bleibt. Wenn man jetzt wieder erwartet, gewinnt er, bleibt er natürlich auf jeden Fall. Es wurde ja auch, das haben wir nicht gesagt, er verabredet bis Winter, dass er sicher Trainer bleibt. Auch das ist ja eine Formulierung, mit der man sich ein bisschen in die Bridulie gebracht hat. Denn man hätte ja sagen können, bis auf Weiteres machen andere ja auch. Also Jan Regensbock war Interimstrainer. Paz heißt er, glaube ich. Wir haben ja auch gesagt, bis auf Weiteres ist er Trainer. Und den Führer hat man gesagt, nein, der bleibt erst mal bis zum Winter. Das waren halt acht Spiele bis zum Winter und acht auch richtungsweisende Spiele. Insofern muss man jetzt gerade ein bisschen so rumlavieren, um dieses, na ja, schauen wir mal, was die Länderspielpause und so weiter. Aber wie gesagt, wenn es einigermaßen gut geht in Köln, bleibt er und ansonsten kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es auch leider wieder zu Ende geht, auch wenn ich ihn als Mensch sehr sympathisch finde als Trainer, seine fußballerische Idee gut finde. Und auch die U23, die er vorher in Fürth ja trainiert hatte, die war auch sehr erfolgreich. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dann so einfach geht, dass er wieder zurückgeht. Das wäre dann auch für einen Trainer, der schon mal in der 2. Liga war, vielleicht nicht dankbar. Aber er ist ja hier unter Vertrag, insofern wird er die 2. Mannschaft wieder übernehmen. Aber wenn ich einen Wunsch äußern darf, geht sein Wochenende-Flitz unentschieden aus. 1 zu 1, so ein ganz biederes 1 zu 1. Und Fürth sagt, wir behalten ein Leo Haas-Fest. Er bekommt die Letterspielpause. Und dann in der Rückrunde spielt Fürth 1 auf.
Ja, sonst sage ich an der Stelle schon mal Finger weg von Mitch Kniart. Bielefeld ist nämlich die defensiv stärkste Mannschaft der Welt.
Der Name fiel in Fürth schon mal, Eva.
Weißt du was, Michi? Bis jetzt war ich glücklich.
Tatsächlich, weil Michael Mutzel, der in Bielefeld ja auch in der sportlichen Verantwortung ist, auch schon mal in der sportlichen Verantwortung war. Deswegen habe ich diesen Namen mitgekniert. Mehrfach gehört nicht nur aus deinem Munde.
Ja, Mensch.
Aber Fürth hat kein Geld, um einen Trainer rauszukaufen. Insofern ist ja alles gut.
Ich würde sagen, Bielefeld nimmt es im Zweifel auch. Aber wir sind ja im Gegensatz zu euch in der dritten Pokalrunde. Von daher brauchen wir die 1,3 Millionen. Nein, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht nicht so unbedingt. Aber bevor mir jetzt zu einem handfesten Streit ausbricht, das Jan Lukas und Michi hier schon klären wollen, wer am Wochenende gewinnt am Podcast-Tisch, würde ich euch erstmal beiden danken, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid. Ich gefühlt habe mir mehr über alle Thematiken neben dem Platz gesprochen als auf dem Platz. Oder zumindest ein solides 50-50. Vielen Dank dafür, Jan Lukas, dass du uns das so berichtet hast vorm FC.
Ja, sehr, sehr gerne.
Und natürlich auch lieben Dank an Michi Fischer. Ich verspreche dir nächstes Mal, bis du hier. Da führt es bestimmt wieder besser. Ich mache heute sehr viele Versprechungen. Ich sollte das nicht bleiben lassen.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt. Aber danke dir, Eva.
Und dann auch noch zum Schluss ein ganz, ganz schnelles Housekeeping. Und zwar bedanke ich mich noch stellvertretend bei Florian Turburis, L2X, Thomas Marx und Felix Kress für eure Unterstützung im Rasenfunk. Und ich habe euch noch einen Artikel von der Sportschau zum Thema Fußballvereiner auf X in den Show notes verlinkt. Und sonst verabschiede ich mich. Wir hören uns. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.